Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Musik Voller Elan hört man Florentin schon im Hintergrund. Das ist er, unser Florentin. Ich hoffe, wir können das aufrechterhalten. Der auch heute wieder bei der Folge dabei ist. Ich moderiere schon, ich moderiere schon an. Kannst du nicht so aus dem Nichts Einfachen anfangen zu hören. Na klar, ich bin schon im Moderationsmodus, hey. Wenn das deine erste vernünftige Anmoderation sein soll, dann muss es ein bisschen professioneller kommen. Okay, wir sind on air in drei, zwei... Es ist 18.16 Uhr, herzlich willkommen zum Podcast UFO Folge 23. Gegenübersitz von mir natürlich auch wieder Florentin Willen, der ist mit dabei. Hallo Florentin. Herzlich willkommen, vielen Dank für diese tolle Einleitung, natürlich mir gegenüber sitzt mein Kompagnon und Weggefährte Stefan Titzel. Kompagnon hat in dieser Anmoderation nichts verloren, ein Wort, das in dieser Moderation einfach nicht passte. Aber kein Problem, das verzeihen wir die Hörlomanabe. Das ist durch Haudegen, Grenzgänger oder Miesepeter, je nachdem. Viel Spaß. Wir freuen uns auf eine Stunde. Ja, warum denn? Warum? Ich weiss nicht, wir haben, glaube ich, so viele neue Hörer bekommen in der letzten Woche, dass wir jetzt natürlich schon von einem ganz anderen Level an Publikum sitzen. Wir haben viele neue Hörer bekommen, wir waren, ich weiß gar nicht mehr auf welchen... Das müssen wir kurz mal aufarbeiten. Also, ich bin nicht genau mit unserer Marketingabteilung verknüpft, also habe ich nicht genau mitbekommen, warum. War das jetzt unsere, waren das die Flyer, die wir verteilt haben? Haben die jetzt endlich den Erfolg gebracht, den wir wollten? Ja, die USB-Sticks. Wir haben ja die ersten 22 Folgen komplett auf USB-Sticks geladen und die in den Fußgängerzonen ausgeworfen, also von Dächern. Und ich glaube, das hat Früchte getragen.
Wir haben Leute beworfen von Dächern mit USB-Sticks, das war der Plan.
Ja, absolut. Das heisst, wir können jetzt auch relativ klar schon die Grenze ziehen zwischen den alten, coolen Nostalgie-Oldschool-Hörern und den neuen, lamen, ich mache jetzt auch bei diesem tollen, hippen Podcast mit Berlin Mitte, ich hole mir jetzt auch einen Chai-Tea-Latte- Grande mit Sojamilch dazu. Das heißt, wir haben jetzt Hörer Erste Ordnung und Hörer Zweite Ordnung. Der Aufruf geht natürlich ganz klar raus, diese beiden Gruppen dürfen sich nicht treffen. Ich will nicht, dass einer von euch Erste Ordnung Hörern morgen auf dem Schulhof sich an den Tisch der Zweite Ordnung Hörer setzt. Nein, das muss ganz klar getrennt bleiben.
Wir haben da auch eine ganz klare Vorstellung. Also wir antworten auch nur den Leuten erster Klasse. Also man kann sich aber auch hocharbeiten. Also je nachdem, wie viel man spendet bei flatter.com slash das Podcast UFO oder so, kann man sich, ja, weiß ich nicht. Man kann sich jedenfalls hocharbeiten, je nachdem, wie man mit uns umgeht und wie man mit uns Nachrichten schreibt oder ob man Rückmeldungen schreibt, Feedback schreibt. Ich würde sagen, die Hörer zweiter Ordnung müssen jetzt einfach auf die höhere dritte Ordnung warten, die in der nächsten Staffel sozusagen kommen. Die haben dann auch jemanden, auf dem sie runterhacken können, aber Staffel, wer erste Ordnung ist, der kommt noch nicht mehr runter. Also wer damals noch die Glücksbärchis angeschaut hat beim Fernsehen, die Turtles samstagmorgen, zusammen mit Luke Mockridge vorm Fernseher saß und gesagt hat, darüber werde ich in fünf Jahren mein Stand-Up-Programm schreiben. So, das waren zwei Minuten 21. Nach zwei Minuten 51 waren wir bei Luke Mockridge. Sehr gut. Wir wollen nämlich diese Folge, in dieser Folge wollen wir über das sprechen, was uns früher bewegt hat. Wir wollen über Nostalgie sprechen. Stopp, jetzt erstmal ganz kurz da muss ich ganz kurz sagen, ich finde es toll, dass wir bei zwei Minuten 51 erst bei Luke Mockridge waren. Bei der Folge hätte ich gedacht, so nach zwölf Sekunden ist der Name schon drin. Wir haben es ausgehalten. Nee, aber ich möchte jetzt auch, ich habe viele Beschwerden bekommen, was diesen Podcast angeht, und zwar zu unserem Gesinge. Und dass wir zu viel singen und dass es nicht gut ankommt. Ich will jetzt aber nicht, ehrlich gesagt, dass es so rüberkommt, als oh, wir haben jetzt 500 neue Zuhörer bekommen, wir waren in den Podcast-Charts auf, weiss ich gar nicht, Platz sechs oder acht oder irgendwie sowas, und dass es jetzt so rüberkommt, wir würden uns jetzt der Masse anbiedern
und wir würden jetzt nicht mehr singen. Nein,
Leute, da kommt ihr so schnell
nicht raus. Wir ziehen unser Ding durch.
Ja, der Trakt
Cousin Angel
Du wolltest doch,
was ich mir überlegt habe,
du wolltest doch heute noch über Jurassic Park
reden und vielleicht weißt du Da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da es auch. Und dann kommt der T-Rex und dann kommt der Brachiosaurus und dann hauen die die Menschen kaputt.
Und Chris Pratt ist mittlerweile Star. So wurden frühe Lieder geschrieben.
Beethovens Fünfte, Beethovens Fünfte.
Ist vielleicht das beste Stück, das jemals geschrieben wurde. So wurden frühe Lieder geschrieben.
Aber ich glaube, der war schon so ein kleiner Downy dann am Ende. Der hat nicht mehr so viel gehört und hat einfach irgendwie so richtig gelangt und auf die Tasten gehauen. Ja, das hat ein bisschen was von so einer 14-jährigen Teenagerin. So ein bisschen. Ja, der war auch so genervt von seinen Fans und dachte, komm, jetzt ist ein Song für euch. So stelle ich mir das im Prenzlauer Berg vor, wenn diese hocherzogenen Kinder irgendwie keinen Bock haben. Räum dein Zimmer auf, Bianca, Septina, Stefania. Ne, ne, ne, ne, so kommt das dann rüber. Ich wohne in einer Wohnung, wo gerade über mir irgendwer Klavier lernt oder so. Und ich finde es toll, dass er einfach komplett keinen Fortschritt macht, sondern bei jedem Tag, jetzt ist er sich pünktlich irgendwann so gegen 18 Uhr einfach ans Klavier und spielt Tonleitern. Und ich weiß nicht, das macht doch keinen Bock. Also wenn man dann versucht, mal wenigstens einen Song zu spielen, der super einfach ist, oder wenigstens alle meine Entchen oder irgendwie sowas, oder Elise hat am Anfang zwei Töne, das kann man durchziehen, nur eine Stunde. Also mir würde das eine Stunde Spaß machen, aber eine Tonleiter zu spielen die ganze Zeit und einfach die ganze Zeit Er ist auch für alle Nachbarn nervig.
Vielleicht ist es auch nur eine Katze, die auf dem Klavier sitzt. Ja, vielleicht.
Ich wohne ja tatsächlich gegenüber meiner Nachbarin, ist ja Klavierlehrerin, das heisst, ich habe einen regen Durchfluss an vierzehnjährigen Mädchen, die ständig an meiner Haustür vorbeigeben und zu ihr in die Wohnung.
Und das heisst, ich höre eigentlich jeden Nachmittag ununterbrochen dasselbe Stück erst schlecht, dann gut, dann dreimal schlecht, dann einmal gut, dann viermal schlecht und dann kommt die nächste Person und dann vielleicht das nächste Lied genau in dieser Taktung einfach immer wieder. Und es ist wirklich anstrengend, aber es ist ganz nett. Bringt sie denn jedem Schüler immer nur dieses Lied vorbei? Jeder Schüler hat ein eigenes Lied, aber das wird genau immer in diesem Rhythmus gespielt.
Du kannst dann immer genau abwarten, jetzt kommt es erstmal wieder viermal schlecht und dann kannst du wieder zuhören und gefällt es sich. Ich würde dann mal die Leute auf dem Flur anhalten und sagen, so, das war jetzt die fünfte Woche in Folge, wo das Lied gar nicht geklappt hat, was ist noch zu Hause los? Hast du auch nicht geübt oder so? Einfach mal die Kinder so im Flur konfrontieren damit. Ja, auch die Musiklehrerin so als Druckmittel. Mir ist es egal, ob du übst oder nicht, aber Florentin Will von nebenan hat gesagt, wenn du das jetzt nicht so langsam auf die Reihe kriegst, dann wird es dir ernsthafte Konsequenzen geben, deswegen streng dich mal ein bisschen an. Jetzt noch eine Frage an dich. Wir reden ja hier gerade über Skype, und ich meine, zum Thema Skype-Profilbilder. Während du den Satz gesagt hast, ist zwischendurch deine Stimme zu so einer Cyborg-Stimme geworden. Das hat man ja manchmal, wenn man miteinander mit jemandem spricht, dass man plötzlich immer so einen Kröck drin hat. Und dann genau bei, wir reden ja gerade bei Skype miteinander, genau da kam gerade so ein geiler Effekt. Das war sehr gut. Ich glaube, Skype merkt das auch, wenn das Wort Skype verwendet wird. Das zählt einfach immer mit, wie das Wort Skype verwendet wird und kriegt dann immer eine bessere Verbindung. Das ist wie wenn man im Fernsehen zwinkert, da kommt ja auch mal automatisch dieses Pling. Genau das ist bei Skype. Wenn man über Skype sagt, da kommt immer so ein Mönchgesang. Kauf die Premium-Variante. Genau, so ein bisschen. Und ich meine, über Skype redet man ja auch oft mit Leuten, die man noch gar nicht kennt. Also ich weiß nicht, ob du das auch ab und zu machst, so irgendwie, hey, hast du mal Bock, irgendwie als Gast in einen Podcast zu kommen, dann trifft man sich über Skype und dann sagt natürlich das erste Bild, das Skype-Profilbild sagt natürlich eine Menge aus. Was ist das für ein Mensch, ist es ein Bild von einem selber oder hat man irgendein anderes Bild, an dessen Stelle gewählt, das einen charakterlich ausdrückt, dass man irgendwie so ein Symbol hat. Was ist denn dein Skype-Profilbild? Meinst du eine Gitarre? Nein, ein Skype-Profilbild ist eine Gitarre. Und das heißt, du bist Musiker, du definierst dich als, also ist ja nicht nur eine Gitarre, ist ja eine, sag ich mal, eine Rock'n'Roll-Gitarre. Also das ist ja schon mal, das ist ja eine Klampfe, da wird ja schon mal ordentlich geschrubbelt auf dem Ding. Das ist mir gar nicht bewusst gewesen, was ich für ein Bild habe. Was habe ich denn für ein Bild? Man sieht ja sein eigenes Bild nicht. Doch, der Adler. Skype hat nämlich so eine super nonchalante Auswahl an so ein paar Bildern, die man wählen kann. Und es ist der Adler dabei, es ist eine Gitarre dabei, es sind diese Windows-Standardbilder dabei eigentlich. Da habe ich dann irgendwann mal die Gitarre genommen, einfach so gedankenlos. Aber man müsste natürlich, das ist ein grober Fehler im Internet, ein sehr grober Fehler, einfach gedankenlos irgendwas zu nehmen. Schön, dass du das in Papagei hast. Es ist ein Fehler, gedankenlos einfach ein Bild auszuwählen, weil der erste Blick im Internet ist immer sehr entscheidend. Extrem wichtig, ja. Es gibt keine zweite Chance für den ersten Eindruck, sage ich oft. Seitdem du den Papagei hast, ist die Qualität der Stimme drastisch gesunken. Und ich sage auch immer wieder dasselbe, ich wiederhole immer dasselbe wieder. Zum Bonus. Nee, aber jetzt mal ganz kurz, du spielst ja auch Gitarre, es ist ja nicht so, als ob das jetzt nur irgendwie so ein vorgeschobenes Image wäre, das du gar nicht erfüllst, nein, du bist ja wirklich Musiker, du spielst Gitarre, du hast in deiner Zuhause, in deiner Liebesfalle, habe ich gehört, drei Gitarren an der Wand hängen, so dass wenn eine Dame den Raum betritt, sofort eigentlich mit gespreizten Beinen aufs Bett fällt und so sagen, drei Gitarren, hallo, was soll ich denn noch dagegen machen, ich bin auch nur ein Mensch. Und deswegen wollte ich dich mal fragen, was ist eigentlich die Motivation davon, selbst ein Instrument zu spielen? Also warum, warum macht man das, warum spielt man eher, also du drehst ja auch seine eigenen Filme. Ja, genau, aber hauptsächlich spiele ich ein eigenes Instrument und habe jahrelang zur Musikschule gegangen mit einer Tasche, die viel zu gross war für meinen kleinen Körper und habe einfach das durchgezogen und geübt und geübt und geübt, damit ich einen Grund dafür hatte, eine Gitarre an die Wand zu hängen. Es sieht nämlich wahnsinnig gut aus, eine Gitarre an der Wand hängen zu haben oder zwei,, drei ist natürlich Optimalfall, vier bis drei Meter geht es dann wieder bergab, aber
drei Gitarren an der Wand zu haben ist schon toll.
Also dafür habe ich das Ganze gerne auf mich genommen.
Damit deutlicher wie du mich fragen und darauf ansprechen
und ich im Podcast sagen kann, hey, ich habe zu Hause
eine Gitarre an der Wand hängen, hey, mag ich mal
vorbeikommen, das so ein Grund eigentlich.
Ja, das stimmt. Falls ihr
Stefan Tizze kennenlernen wollt, die Adresse
findet ihr auf unserer Facebook-Seite, die wir an der Seite
auch nochmal ein bisschen pushen können. Wir haben jetzt viele neue Zuhörer und da gehört natürlich so ein bisschen die Marketingmaschine rollt natürlich. Das ist mir, danke schön. Das merkt man natürlich, Flatter geht durch die Decke, Facebook, Twitter, da könnt ihr uns überall erreichen und da freuen wir uns natürlich auf euren Kontakt und euren Input und alles andere, was ihr sonst noch machen wollt. Aber es ist ja nicht bei vielen Sachen so, also Instrumente, Musik ist ja eines der wenigen Dinge, die man auch akzeptiert selbst macht. Man schaut sich Filme an, dreht aber keine eigenen Filme. Man geht irgendwie ins Ballett, tanzt aber nicht notwendigerweise selber. Aber man hört Musik und viele Leute akzeptieren auch, dass man selber Musik spielt. Aber warum? Also was ist der Vorteil, selber Musik zu spielen, anstatt Musik zu hören von Leuten, die es besser können als du? Das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Das ist aber genauso. Erstmal ist es ja bei jedem Ding so, was man gerne macht. Wenn du gerne Fussball guckst, gibt es auch viele, die das einfach dann so gerne machen, dass sie auch gerne Fussball spielen würden. Oder die Tennis gucken und dann Tennis spielen. Dann gibt es auch Leute, die so gerne Musik hören und so gerne Musik machen, dass sie dann halt automatisch zur Gitarre greifen. Das ist halt ganz normal und das ist auch okay. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum das so ein Ding für dich ist. Ich habe zum Beispiel mal eine Gehörgangsentzündung gehabt in beiden Ohren und habe nichts mehr gehört. Und ich konnte aber trotzdem noch... Du hast so so gespielt wie... Genau, ich konnte aber trotzdem noch Gitarre spielen, weil ich habe dann einfach mein Kinn auf den Korpus der Gitarre gelegt und durch die Vibration, die die Gitarre durch meinen Schädel durchgeführt haben, konnte ich trotzdem noch das hören.
Obwohl ich sonst nichts mehr hören konnte.
Und es sah doch schon super toll aus, wenn so ein ganz kleiner Junge mit dem Kinn auf die Gitarre gepresster sitzt und so ganz angeschränkt versucht zu spielen. Ja, das war super toll. Das sagte ich mir zum Beispiel auch mal bei Forrest Gump, da gibt es ja am Ende diese Szene, wo seine Freundin irgendwie, Jenny glaube ich, dann irgendwie in so einer abgerissenen Kneipe nackt Gitarre gespielt hat, wo ich mir auch dachte, sehr gute Instrumentwahl, sehr gut gelöst, Gitarre perfekt, wenn man nackt spielen muss ein Instrument, fantastisch, man kann vielleicht noch einen Kontrabass spielen oder ein Klavier, aber wenn du mit einer Triangel dastehst, ist es natürlich blöd, dann ist der Effekt
natürlich auch nicht so. Es sei denn, du hast den perfekten Triangelkörper.
Wenn du den perfekten Triangelkörper hast,
habe ich schon erst einmal in meinem Leben gesehen,
aber dann ist es perfekt.
Ja, oder du hast deine Geschlechtsorgane, sind genau so angeordnet
vielleicht. Ja, du musst mal ganz kurz gucken,
dass du deine Internetverbindung wieder eingeführt bekommst, weil ich verstehe
dich nicht gut. Weil ich sage mal Papageien, wenn du den Papageien
noch kurz ans Profil wegmachen würdest. Ja, ich habe
gerade 80 Tabs offen, ich lade gerade Twilight
tatsächlich, ich habe mir gerade, also bis zu dem Moment, als du angerufen hast. Du musst
echt aufhören, ich verstehe dich gar nicht mehr, ich verstehe dich gar nicht mehr.
Also bis zu dem Moment, als du angerufen hast, habe ich mir gerade auf Netflix Twilight
angeschaut tatsächlich, weil ich habe gesehen, das ist zur Verfügung und warum kann man
nicht mal reinschauen ein bisschen, warum kann man nicht auch mal sagen, hey, das ist
was passiert, das hat irgendwie 50 Millionen, 14jährige Mädchen berührt auf eine Art.
Ich will gucken, was da dahinter steckt.
Ja, vor allem, du machst auch mal da Witze, also du als professioneller Gag-Schreiber machst auch immer Witze darüber, gerade über Twilight.
Ja, ich mache jeden Tag Gags über Twilight, klar, die kommen wahnsinnig gut an auf Twitter, wenn du heute noch Gags über Twilight machst.
Ich weiß zufällig genau, dass du gerade an einem Twilight-Parodie-Buch schreibst, diese ganzen Gags, die du da schreibst. Da musst du auch erstmal einordnen können, du musst aber wissen, woher die kommen. Das sind diese Dinge, also eigentlich ist es Pflicht eines Comedy-Autors, alle Dinge zu wissen, genau Bescheid zu wissen über die Dinge, ob er dir Witze macht, finde ich. Meine Meinung, hey. Auch dieses Wortspiel mit dem Bis zum Morgengrauen, mit diesem Bis mit einem S2 ist. Ist schon toll. Für mich ein Comedy-Geniestreich. Auch das so lange durchzuziehen. Nach dem ersten Film haben sich ja da schon alle drüber lustig gemacht und gesagt, was ist das für eine beschissene Idee, das ist doch wirklich das dümmste Wortspiel, das es gibt, und warum will man überhaupt ein Wortspiel in einem Film haben, der jetzt nicht unbedingt eine Komödie ist, warum überhaupt? Was soll das? Das ist die einzige Nicht-Komödie, die ein Wortspiel im Titel direkt ... Was soll das? Man hätte es ja auch Vampire 1, 2 und 3 nennen können, aber es soll halt diesen romantischen Aspekt beinhalten. Und dann sollte es halt beinhalten, dass es um Babiss-Vampire geht. Und dann irgendwie wollte man beides zusammenbekommen, da war sich die Markboschule nicht ganz einig. Ja, aber denkst du, Babiss automatisch an Vampire? Es könnte auch eine Kochshow sein. Wenn ich jetzt höre, bis zum Morgengrauen, denke ich nicht automatisch an Vampire. Geil, Frühstück, wie mache ich ein gutes Frühstück? Oder ein Kannibalendrama oder sowas. Also ich meine, da gibt es ja wahnsinnig viele verschiedene Facetten. Biss ist ja nicht nur jetzt von Vampiren belegt. Ich lasse mir das doch nicht wegnehmen. Das ist gerade irgendwie so ein Podcast Level 2 gerade, weil ich verstehe nicht genau, was du sagst, ich verstehe nur den Anfang und das Ende des Satzes und ich versuche immer so nebenbei, das Anforderungslevel ist ein bisschen gestiegen. Ich versuche immer so, was hat er gesagt dazwischen, wo ist die Stimme hochgegangen, welche, oh Gott, oh Gott. Dafür, dass mein Internet zusammenbricht, ist deine Stimme zusammen, so RL-Disconnect so ein bisschen. Oh, ich habe ja einen Müsli verschluckt gerade. Isst du gerade Müsli? Ja, nebenbei, so mit einem Teller Müsli. Ah, ich trinke gerade einen Tee nebenbei.
Da merkt man auch ein bisschen, dass wir routinierter werden, dass wir anfangen, Dinge nebenbei zu... Alles in Ordnung? Soll ich kurz rüberkommen?
Stefan, geht's dir gut?
Oh Gott, oh Gott.
Go Butler, soll ich kurz Go Butler informieren?
Ich habe so laut gehustet, dass die Klavierspielerin aufgehört, in Toiletern zu spielen, eben vom Klaviergefallen.
Oh Gott.
So.
Alles in Ordnung?
So, aber es geht wieder. Es ist rausgekommen.
Also jetzt nochmal. Okay. Also jetzt nochmal. So. Du lernst auch nicht aus deinen Fehlern. Ich weiß ja nicht, wie es dir geht, aber ich bin so ein Typ, ich freue mich, ich habe mir auch ein Gameboy gekauft, weil ich einfach das Gefühl nochmal haben wollte, wie man damals Gameboy gespielt hat. und ich habe mir auch noch mal ich bin auch ein riesen Star Wars Fan
auch jetzt, vielleicht ist es ein bisschen gekommen
dadurch, wie man damals Gameboy gespielt hat. Und ich hab mir auch nochmal, ich bin auch ein riesen Star Wars Fan, auch jetzt, vielleicht ist es ein bisschen gekommen, dadurch, dass man jetzt ja quasi wieder auf neun Filmen warten kann, da hat man wieder diese Gefühle, die ja hochkommen und wo man Bock hat, wieder das Glaserschwert rauszukramen und durch den Garten zu laufen und mit den Kindern, mit Nachbarskindern irgendwie zu kämpfen oder so. Das war nämlich echt ohne Scheiss. Gerade bis fünf Minuten vor der Aufnahme haben Kinder draußen im Garten, Kinder draußen im Garten vor der Wohnung haben mit Laserschwertern gekämpft. Und da hatte ich Bock mitzumachen, da hatte ich Bock mitzumachen, war ein bisschen nervig, während er in Fussball gespielt, ich weiß auch nicht, was das für eine crazy Sportart ist, mit Laserschwertern zu kämpfen und nebenbei Fussball zu spielen, habe ich auch noch nicht so gesehen, verstehe ich auch nicht ganz. Aber du kannst dann so als Sith Lord rausgehen, du kannst dir dann deinen schwarzen Morgenmantel oder deinen pinken Morgenmantel, je nachdem, sogar den Kopf ziehen und dann so langsam rausschweben als Sith und die grosse Bedrohung spielen. Ich habe gehört, dass es bei den Eltern auch immer gut ankommt, wenn man im Bademantel mit den Kindern spielt. Auf die Kinder losgeht, ja. Ich glaube, das finden die Eltern immer ganz toll, habe ich mal irgendwo gelesen. Ich finde deine Wohnsituation so lustig, die Vorstellung, dass du im Erdgeschoss wohnst, mit einer Liebeskorte, wo überall so Frotte an den Wänden hängt. Fellwände, ich habe Fellwände, ja. Gitarren nebenbei und dann noch so ein Bilder, wie du irgendwie im Jugendtheaterstück aufgetreten bist und überall Blumen hast, weil du bist ja so ein sentimentaler, romantischer Typ und alles ist so klebrig wie in so einer Fallen, wie heißen diese Pflanzenfallen, Fallenpflanzen,
so dass wenn eine Frau da reinkommt, sich überhaupt nicht mehr bewegen kann,
die klebt einfach an der Wand fest und hat keine Chance mehr.
Ich habe sehr viele falsch rissende Pflanzen in der Wohnung, weil ich mal irgendwann, ich hätte mal ein Obstfliegen.
Dankeschön.
Für die, die später eingestiegen sind, ich hätte mal ein Obstfliegenproblem.
Nee, wir wiederholen keine Story.
Doch, auf jeden Fall kurz.
Und da habe ich mir dann fleissrissende Pflanzen gekauft und die ist alles voller, die vermehren sich wie Sau
und überall stehen fleissrissende Pflanzen, wachsen aus denänden. Und man muss wirklich aufpassen hier, wo man hintritt. Trotzdem, obwohl irgendwie den ganzen Tag George Michael läuft, bist du trotzdem noch in der normalen Wohnsendung im Erdgeschoss und hast keine Vorhänge. Und im Fenster spielen die ganze Zeit Kinder, die konstant auch bei dir zu Fenster reinschauen. Was mir tatsächlich mehrmals schon beim ICE passiert ist, dass ich sitze im ICE immer am Fenster, ja, Wagen 33, Platz 85, der beste Platz, den es gibt bei ICEs, wenn ihr mal buchen müsst und nicht wisst, welchen Platz ihr reservieren sollt, Wagen 33, Platz 85, merkt es euch, der beste Platz. Man sitzt am Fenster und dann passiert es oft irgendwie, dass jemand neben mir oder noch weiter neben mir sitzt und dann guckt, also letztens zum Beispiel wurde so ein Junge neben mir platziert von seiner Mutter hier und dann hatte ich meinen Laptop draus und dann er auch so gleich so ah, guck mal, noch jemand, der sich für Computer interessiert. Und einfach schon bei mir so Fremdscham und beim Jungen auch schon. Ich verstehe dich gar nicht mehr. Sorry, ich verstehe dich echt gar nicht. Es tut mir echt leid, ich verstehe nicht, was du sagst. Ich habe mittlerweile meinen Browser geschlossen, ich habe mittlerweile nichts mehr, was irgendwo die Verbindung stehren könnte. Das kann nicht sein. Ich kann auch noch mein Mailprogramm schliessen, wenn es sein muss. Ich schließe auch mal, Tweetdeck ist auch krass, Tweetdeck ist auch krass, zieht echt viel. Von mir aus. Muss man mal sagen. Warte, mache ich Spotify zu, Steam mache ich zu, mache ich alles zu, von mir aus. Steam läuft dabei noch so ein riesen MMORPG oder so, ist ihm scheißegal. Mein Minecraft-Server gerade gehostet. Ne, auf jeden Fall saß dann dieser kleine verängstigte Junge neben mir und die Mutter ist dann noch so raus auf den Bahnsteig gegangen und als der Zug losgefahren ist, hat sie so zu Fenster reingeguckt und so ganz energisch gewinkt, so extrem energisch dem Jungen zugewunken. Der hat seine Mutter nicht mal angeschaut, weil es ihm so peinlich war und hat einfach nur nach vorne gestarrt, weil die Situation so unangenehm war. Und irgendwann habe ich dann einfach angefangen, der Mutter zurückzuwinken, weil ich die Situation so unangenehm fand, zu sehen, wie eine Mutter, die jetzt gerade irgendwie ihr Kind in Konzentrationslager schickt oder was auch immer, irgendwie in Zug setzt zum bösen Stiefvater und winkt mit Tränen in den Augen ihrem Kind zu und der Sohn winkt nicht zurück, dass ich mir dachte, ich kenne hier niemanden, aber ich muss jetzt stellvertretend zurückwinken. Auch gar nicht, dass du auf den Gedanken gekommen bist, dass es für die Mutter vielleicht viel schlimmer ist, wenn ein fremder Junge zurückwirkt, als wenn gar nichts kommt einfach. Dass sie es noch weniger haben wollte. Ja, das ist einfach so ein Reflex, wenn jemand zuwinkt, dass man dann einfach auch mal zurückwinkt irgendwie.
Bisschen komisch, aber naja.
Naja, wie gesagt, ich wollte nochmal auf diese Star-Wars-Geschichte zurück und ich bin ein Riesenfan.
Ja, ich weiß, ich versuche das Thema immer zu verzögern.
Okay, ich bin gespannt, wie du das nächste Mal hinkriegst.
Ich erzähl mal weiter, du kannst dann irgendwann nachzwischensteigen, wenn du die Möglichkeit siehst.
Ich bin gespannt, wo das sein wird.
Dinosaurier, okay, los. Das gibt auch noch die andere Melodie von Jurassic Park. Du warst ja im Star Wars Museum. Das ist echt uncool von dir. Das Einzige, was wir noch schlimmer machen können, ist zu sagen, du hast ja die beste Geschichte der Welt im Star Wars Museum erlebt. Erzähl doch mal, wie war das denn so? Das war noch zeitiger gewesen, aber das ist auch schon schlecht. Ja, ich war im Star Wars Museum. Es war wirklich toll, man kommt da hin, dann kriegt man erst mal so einen Transponder um, dass man irgendwie, wenn man in bestimmten Bereichen steht, hört man auf dem Kopfhörer, hört man dann so Geschichten. Ganz kurzer Einschnitt, ganz kurz, damit die Zuschauer und ich mir das besser vorstellen können. Beschreib doch mal ein bisschen das Publikum in einem Star-Wars-Museum. Mit wem warst du da unterwegs? Man kommt erst mal in so einem Raum, wo Han Solo einem sagt, warum man ist. Und dann ist es
ein Raum, wo man erstmal den ganzen Film sehen muss,
ein Erklärvideo, und dann öffnet sich der
Raum und man kann durch die Ausstellung gehen
und kriegt hier mal Infos und da Infos und du kannst
auch interaktiv mitmachen. Und in diesem Raum
am Anfang war schon relativ deutlich, zu sehen,
was die Zielgruppe ist.
Es sind alte,
dicke Männer in
verwaschenen Star-Wars-Anzügen
oder Pyjamas. Ich weiß nicht genau,
ob die jeweils, ob die
Vielen Dank. Es sind alte, dicke Männer in verwaschenen Star-Wars-Anzügen oder Pyjamas. Ich weiß nicht genau, ob diese T-Shirts, die sie getragen haben, immer als T-Shirts benutzt wurden oder manchmal auch als Pyjamas benutzt wurden. Oder manchmal schon als Lappen, um Töpfe abzuwischen oder so. Solche Männer, die oft sehr dick sind, sehr lange Haare haben, eigentlich so wie man bei diesem Simpsons, dieser Simpsons Comic-Typ. Der Comic-Book-Guy, ja.
Der sieht genauso aus, Schwangerschaftshosen tragende,
mit Vierziger,
das war so die Zielgruppe.
Finde ich sehr sympathisch. Das ist die einzige
Zielgruppe, in der ich mich übergeordnet
fühle.
Eigentlich so. Das war sehr
toll. Und nebenbei
konnte man dann wirklich so interaktiv seinen eigenen Jedi erstellen. War ganz cool, besonders für die Kinder da und für die besagte Zielgruppe der dicklichen Schwangerschaftshosen Tragende war das auch sehr interessant, weil die wollten natürlich dann die richtig coolen Jedis haben und die haben natürlich auch nicht die Jedis genommen, wie jeder normale Mensch da, sondern die haben sich dann irgendwie so einen Bounty Hunter, so einen Kopfgeldjäger erstellt und dann so die coolsten, den coolsten haben sich ausgelaufen und haben es richtig ernst genommen. Und am Ende gab es dann diese Situation, dass man halt so große Video-Leinwand vor sich hat und dann konnte man sein Band, mit dem man die ganze Zeit seinen Jedi erstellen konnte, konnte man dann an die Wand halten und dann hat sich der Jedi gebildet, den man die ganze Zeit erstellt hat. Und es war halt, bei allen war das so random mässig und die hatten sich halt wirklich Mühe gegeben. Es war einfach wahnsinnig cool, die Geschichte, die da erstellen ist, war dann wahnsinnig cool. Die haben es echt ernst genommen, das war ganz lustig. Du bist mittlerweile auch, lebst du noch? Ich habe mich gerade verschluckt. Siehste mal, siehste mal. Wahnsinn, ne, ich habe mich gerade mal meinem Tee verschluckt. Ja, was hast du denn für einen Jedi dir geholt? Ich hatte, das ist ja sehr nerdig, ne? Aber ich hatte Admiral Akbar, diese Rasse. Diese, man weiß nicht genau, ist es ein Fisch, ist es so Schrimp, so Schrimpmäßige Klasse war das. Die hießen Mon Calamari, hießen die sogar. Mon Calamari. Es ist so schwer, das ernst zu nehmen. Selbst als Hardcore-Fan, glaube ich, muss man da sagen, nee. Es waren Originalrequisiten da. Es waren Originalrequisiten da, es waren Modelle da, es waren sehr viele interaktive Punkte da, wo man Geschichten erzählt bekommen hat, dann waren, und dann irgendwie zwischendurch, um halt seinen Jedi erstellen zu können, dann gab es da so Abschnitte, ja, die ersten Ereignisse, die einen Charakter prägen, die Freunde, die einen Charakter prägen, und dann konnte man sich in so Bereiche stellen und so einen Erklärfilm anhören, der aber gar nichts mit Star Wars zu tun hatte, der nichts mit Star Wars zu tun hatte, einfach so, wo einfach, ja, Menschen bestehen aus Zellen und dann hat man irgendwann Freunde und die Freunde, mit denen man abhängt, die formen einen Charakter. Schritt zwei, Schritt eins zählen. Und dann die ersten Ereignisse, die man erlebt, die formen einen. Wenn du ein Fussballturnier gewinnst, ja, fuck Fussballturnier, ich bin bei Star Wars Ausstellung, ich bin bei Star Wars Wissen und dann kamen da so Erklärfilme, die nichts damit zu tun hatten, sondern die einfach irgendwie mit Charakterbildung zu tun hatten.
Ich weiß jetzt perfekt, ich weiß nichts über Star Wars mehr, aber ich weiß, wie Charakter gebildet wird. Also ich weiß genau, wie ich ticke jetzt. Ja, aber das ist doch Star Wars. Star Wars, da geht es doch um die Entwicklung, darum, dass man den richtigen Weg geht, dass man eben nicht auf die dunkle Seite der Macht gerät, sondern dass man enge Freunde hat, dass man die Macht in sich spürt. Das ist doch wichtig, auch für die jungen Leute, dass sie nicht nur Star Wars als Heinz-Fiction-Universum, sondern auch die Ideologie, die Philosophie hinter Star Wars verstehen. Das ist doch viel wichtiger. Darum geht es doch eigentlich. Ja, genau. Deswegen lieben wir doch Star Wars. Nicht wegen den X-Fightern und den TIE-Fightern, den X-Wing und den AT-ATs, nee, sondern wegen dem Herzen. Ich habe mir ja aus Lego ein Star Wars AT-ST gekauft, gebe ich hier ganz offen zu. Ich finde das total geil. Ich finde diese Star Wars Sachen von Lego einfach gut. Da habe ich auch gerne mal ein bisschen mehr Geld ausgegeben. Die 1500 Euro waren es mir echt wert, muss man sagen. Liebes eins für die Liebesfalle, würde ich sagen. Naja, es ist schon, es passt schon ins Corporate Design der Wohnung. Ich habe die Vorderung, die in dein Zimmer kommt und sagt, einerseits drei Gitarren an der Wand, andererseits AT-ST aus Logo neben dem Bett. Ja, sind immer noch ein Plus zwei. Am Ende steht immer noch ein Plus zwei. Immer noch Plus zwei, ja. Ich glaube, du kannst dir noch zwei Sünden leisten. Dann musst du allerdings schon langsam vorsichtig sein. Ja, ich hole mir immer für jedes Nerd-Ding, was ich mir hole, hole ich mir eine Gitarre mehr an die Wand. Und irgendwann, das ist immer so mein Rechen. Das Gleichgewicht der Machtbehalten. Ja, und da war es so, da hat ein Teil gefehlt. Also bei diesem Lego-Ding, wo wirklich viele Teile auch drin waren, ist es halt schade, weil man es wirklich auch ins Regal stellt, weil es eigentlich gut aussieht. Da hat ein Teil gefehlt und dann habe ich, und Lego passt ja auch ein bisschen in unser Thema, dachte ich mir, und da erzähle ich mal diese Geschichte, und dann habe ich Lego geschrieben, hört mal, mir fehlt ein Teil und könnt ihr mir das nicht schicken und Und Lego, muss man sagen, ist echt der beste Verein der Welt. Und ich habe mir dann eine Mail geschrieben, das tat mir so leid, das tat mir so leid, dass ich mich beschwert habe. Dann kam so eine Mail zurück, oben links mit diesem süssen Lego-Zeichen, da rechts daneben ist dann so ein kleines süsses Lego-Männchen in so einer Service-Uniform, so ja, Kundenservice, hat so ein Headset um und so ein kleines Lego-Männchen. Und dann steht da drin, ja, dann entschuldigen sie sich so auf fünf, die nach vier Seiten ausgedrückt, entschuldigen sie sich dann, dass ein Teil fehlt und schreiben dann, ja, ich hoffe, es ergibt sich für uns in der Zukunft noch einmal eine Gelegenheit, ihre Erfahrungen und unser Spielzeug zu erfüllen und so ihr Vertrauen zurückzugewinnen. Und ich wollte fast zurücktreiben, behaltet es einfach. Es ist perfekt, es braucht das Teil gar nicht. Ich habe mich vertan, behaltet es einfach. Und jetzt haben die mir dann kostenlos dieses Teil zurückgeschickt und es hat mir wirklich leid, dass ich mich da beschwert habe. Also ich habe mich nicht beschwert, ich habe einfach dieses Teil gefordert. Aber das hat mir echt leid. All die sind schon die Besten. Wie was, Da gibt es ja auch viele Videos im Internet, wo dann irgendwie so ein Kind ewig lang nach einem bestimmten Lego-Set sucht und spart und dann, wenn er genug Geld hat, dann gibt es das Lego-Set nicht mehr von so einem smaragdgrünen Zug und dann schreibt er eben an Lego so von wegen, ich habe zu lange gespart und dann schickt ihm Lego einfach diesen Zug kostenlos. Mal zehnmal. Die sind die letzte Menschen der Welt.
Aber, ja, in den Medien hört man nicht so viel davon, dass diese bunten Legosteine irgendwo in Kambodscha oder Sklaven ähnlichen Bedingungen hergestellt werden. Das glaube ich nicht. Oder vielleicht auch nicht. Ich glaube, die werden in Dänemark selber hergestellt. Ist ein Dänischer Konzern. Lego heisst ja Lego auf Deutsch. Ja, das stimmt. Aber ganz wichtig, wo man echten Lego-Fan von einem Fake-Lego-Fan unterscheiden kann, die Mehrzahl von Lego ist auf gar keinen Fall Legos. Niemals darf man Lego sagen. Die Mehrzahl ist auch Lego. Können wir das mal kurz durchdeklinieren? Lego, Legas, Legat, Legamus, Legatus, Legant. Nee, wir haben jetzt das konjugiert. Es ist, glaube ich, eher Lego, legum, legu, legus, legu, legum, legarum, legis, legus, legis, so eine Art. Sowas in der Richtung, ja. Das heißt, wenn eure Mutter sagt, hey, räum mal deine Legos auf, kann sie sofort sagen, pff, fick dich, Mutter, du hast keine Ahnung, worum es hier geht. Nö, nö, nö, nö, ja, ganz viel aus dem Zimmer stolzieren. Ach Mensch, die alte Zeit, ne, damals, als man noch mit seinen Eltern gestritten hat, als Zimmer aufräumen noch das grösste Problem war, das man hatte und ansonsten einfach Samstagmorgen schön im Pyjama vor den Eltern aufgestanden ist, um noch ein bisschen die guten Cartoons sich anzuschauen, das war schon eine schöne Zeit, Mensch, Ich bin sonntagsmorgenzimmer aufgestanden, ich bin sonntagsmorgenzimmer aufgestanden und habe auf RTL 2 X-Factor das Unfassbare geguckt. Und das war mein Leben. Es ist perfekt. Haben wir aber schon mal gesprochen, dass es nur 49 Folgen davon gibt? Wirklich? Ich habe das Gefühl, da gibt es 180 Folgen. Nein, es gibt nur 49 Folgen und ich habe mich auch relativ früh gefragt, warum ich alle Folgen schon kenne. Da dachte ich mir, bist du so ein Freak jetzt, dass du schon alle Folgen kennst. Aber es gibt nur 49, die irgendwie seit 50 Jahren auf Werte als zwei wiederholt werden und irgendwie noch immer genauso viel Geld reinspielen wie vor tausend Jahren. Und es sind immer nur 49 Folgen, die jemals aufgenommen wurden. Es gab auch nie eine neue Staffel oder so. Jetzt mal ganz kurz, unter uns Pastorentöchtern, X-Faktor das Unfassbare, ist doch von vorne bis hinten Bullshit, oder? Als ob diese wahren Geschichten in irgendeiner Weise auch wahr wären. Wenn überhaupt, gibt es mal irgendeinen Bericht von irgendeiner betrunkenen Witwe, die irgendwie in Katzen irgendwie dann versucht hat zu erzählen, ja, da sind irgendwelche Schaufensterpuppen zum Leben erwacht und da war ich im Keller und dann haben die sich bewegt und die so, okay, klar, passt, ist also wahr. Das war doch alles Bullshit, oder? Das glaube ich auch. Von vorne bis hin. Die sagen ja auch, die basieren auf einer wahren Geschichte. Und ich sag mal, Dinge, die in einer wahren Geschichte passiert sind, sind ja auch nicht passiert. Ja, Harry Potter basiert auch auf einer wahren Geschichte. Das kannst du auch erzählen. Das ist einfach kommentierter Bullshit. Aber trotzdem sass man nur vor so, ne, das ist nicht passiert. Star Wars passiert auch vor der Waren Geschichte, nur halt in einer weit, weit entfernten Galaxis. Die Geschichte ist halt weit, weit entfernt. Man muss sagen, wir haben uns da eigentlich alles abgesichert. Man kann nicht sagen. Vor langer, langer Zeit. Vor langer, langer Zeit. Wo wir uns auch mal diskutiert haben, inwieweit diese in der Vergangenheit. Genau, inwieweit das so wichtig ist zu sagen. Ja, vor allem, viele denken ja, Star Wars sei Science-Fiction irgendwie in der Zukunft, wird es mal genauso sein wie Star Wars mit fliegenden Autos und irgendwelchen Robotern. Nee, Star Wars spielt in der Vergangenheit, vor langer, langer Zeit. Das ist alles schon vorbei, das ist alles schon gewesen. Es wird nicht mehr so, liebe Freunde. Das ist auch nostalgisch, sich an Star Wars, Star Wars ist doppelt nostalgisch. Das liegt doppelt in der Vergangenheit, in seiner Kindheit und einfach nochmal vor 200.000 Jahren wird es auch nochmal gegeben haben. Das ist alles schon vorbei. Daher weiss George Lucas das ja auch. Sonst wüsste er das ja gar nicht, wenn es in der Zukunft liegen würde. Denkt doch mal nach, Leute. Ich frage es dann nur, wie er in diese weit, weit entfernte Galaxis, in diese weit, weit entfernte Galaxis ist. Es ist ja nicht nur ein weit, aber weit weit weg. Er hat sich juristisch komplett absichern. Muss man mal sagen. Du musst mir mal kurz einen Gefallen tun. Für die unendliche Geschichte. Du musst mir mal kurz einen Gefallen tun. Und zwar ist ja wieder Projektarbeitsphase. Und ich bin gerade dabei, so meine Projektarbeiten irgendwie zusammenzubekommen, irgendwie. Und ich habe nicht so gewissenhaft gearbeitet, deswegen musst du mir jetzt mal kurz einen Gefallen tun. Und zwar, ich muss einen O-Ton eines Experten einfügen. Und ich habe den Experten, das habe ich leider nicht, und du bist jetzt der Experte. Du heisst Bernd Heinrich und musst folgenden Satz sagen. Du musst den ohne Scheiß, ich nehme den jetzt hier aus dem Podcast-Ufer einfach dann in meine Projektarbeit auf. Aber du musst ihn mal kurz sagen. Du musst ihn sagen, der Satz ist, der ist rechtlich schon mal einwandfrei, wenn man den politischen Willen hätte, würde man eine Regelung hinbekommen. Okay? Ja. Der ist rechtlich schon mal einwandfrei. Wenn man den politischen Willen hätte, würde man eine Regelung hinbekommen. Okay?
Ja.
Der ist rechtlich schon mal einwandfrei.
Ja, ist schon klar.
Wenn man den politischen Willen hätte, würde man eine Regelung hinbekommen.
Und das ist jetzt echt wichtig. Und du musst es halt so spielen, als wärst du der Experte und würdest das sagen. Es geht um so einen Gesetzesentwurf.
Und der ist rechtlich schon mal einwandfrei.
Okay. Und bist du bereit für den ersten Entwurf?
Ja.
Okay, drei, zwei.
Also das ist rechtlich schon mal einwandfrei.
Wenn man den politischen Willen hätte, könnte man das so durchsetzen.
Dankeschön.
War das der richtige Satz?
War nicht der richtige Satz.
Kannst du mir den Satz nochmal schicken, ganz kurz per Messenger?
Da war schon viel Gutes dabei, fand ich jetzt.
Aber kannst du mir vielleicht eine Frage stellen davor? Dann kann ich es, glaube ich, besser spielen. Wenn du mir eine Frage stellst, auf die ich dann antworte. Okay, warte mal. Ich kann auch eine Rolle spielen, wenn du willst. Ja, also da ist schon eine Menge politischer Willen dabei. Wissen Sie, in Vergangenheit war es ja oft so, dass es, wo kommt Jesus, ach so per Skype, okay. Oh man, ey, das ist ja so scheiße. Der, wer denn? Der ist, also rechtlich ist er schon mal einwandfrei. Du hast mit Kollegen, also ich kurz mal hier ein bisschen Method-Acting, du hast mit Kollegen einen Gesetzesentwurf entwickelt, der wurde aber abgeschmettert mit der Begründung, der wäre rechtlich nicht einwandfrei, ist er aber.
Also musst du sagen, der ist rechtlich schon mal einwandfrei. Also wenn man den politischen Willen hätte, dann würde man auch eine Regelung hinbekommen. Du bist auch so ein bisschen wütend schon, so ein bisschen angepisst von der Gegenpartei. Der ist rechtlich schon mal einwandfrei, wenn man den politischen Willen hätte, würde man die Regelung hinbekommen. Du hast gesagt, ich soll dir vorher eine Frage stellen. Okay. Okay, damit du dich besser reinfühlen kannst. Ja. Warum spielt Star Wars in einer weit, weit entfernten Galaxis? Der ist rechtlich schon mal einwandfrei. Wenn man jetzt noch den politischen Willen hätte, würde man eine Regelung hinbekommen. Danke. Kannst du den ersten Satz noch ein bisschen besser spielen vielleicht? Also da muss ein bisschen... Gute alte Regieanweisung. Kannst du vielleicht nochmal den ersten Satz nochmal besser machen, der zweite schon okay, den ersten nochmal besser. Oder den zweiten schlechter, je nachdem, darf nur kein Gefälle sein. Ja genau, das muss einfach... Aber betonunglich auf rechtlich, der ist rechtlich schon mal einwandfrei. Ne, der ist rechtlich schon mal einwandfrei. So, also der ist rechtlich schon mal einwandfrei, der, der ist schon die Betonung. Die Betonung ist schon auf rechtlich, rechtlich gibt es kein Problem, nur der politische Wille ist das, was fehlt. Der ist rechtlich schon mal einwandfrei. Wenn man jetzt noch den politischen Willen hätte, dann würde man eine Regelung hinbekommen. Danke, das war's. Perfekt. Nochmal, nee, das war ja auch falsch. Nochmal. Komm, stell dir nochmal eine Frage. Dann ist es durch. Bei Bock hast du noch mal Skype improvisieren, eben Improven, dass er da vielleicht nochmal, dass ich dich wieder höre. Aber... Sag mal, sollen wir uns eigentlich die Skype Premium-Version kaufen? So teuer ist die ja eigentlich gar nicht, oder? Ja, hat man dann irgendwie Highspeed Skype oder so? Ja, man hat Highspeed Skype. Also, ich würde schon reich, wenn ich mich hören kann, aber ich höre dich immer nur... Absolut, man hat Highspeed Skype, man kann auch zu Festnetz anrufen anrufen und man hat viele weitere Boni, die das Erlebnis des Skype-Anrufs weiter verbessern. Und wenn man Freunde einlädt, kriegt man Rabatt. Der ist rechtlich schon mal einwandfrei. Wenn man den politischen Willen hätte, würde man eine Regelung hinbekommen. Ja, Dankeschön. Gut, wunderbar, gerne. Dafür sind wir doch da, muss man mal sagen.
Und wie machst du das?
Also wie fügst du das in deine Projektarbeit ein?
Das ist eine Art Radiobeitrag.
Worddokument, wo dann so eine MP3 dabei ist, oder wie?
Ja, wir machen aus unseren Folgen eh immer eine MP3, bevor wir die hochladen.
Dann dachte ich mir, kann ich mir auch einfach den Satz rausnehmen, den du da.
Nee, aber welches Format hat deine Projektarbeit?
Ein Radiobeitrag.
Also nur Audio?
Nur Audio, tatsächlich, ja.
Aha.
Und es ist komplett gefakt von vorne bis hinten, oder was? Alter, ich verstehe dich nicht.
Ich verstehe dich einfach nicht.
Ich bin der Fall. Beitrag. Also nur Audio? Nur Audio, tatsächlich, ja. Aha. Und es ist komplett gefakt von vorne bis hinten, oder was?
Alter, ich verstehe dich nicht. Ich verstehe dich einfach nicht.
Ich höre nicht, was du sagst. Der Radiobeitrag ist komplett gefakt.
Ich höre nicht, was du sagst.
Ja, dann improvisier, dann mach Musik an.
Du bist ganz weg, du bist ganz weg leider.
Ich muss nochmal aufleben.
Okay, Comeback, das grosse Comeback mit Gitarrenbegleitung. Wenn ich mal wieder durchs Gelände eier und mich dabei als lebende Legende feier, Als Selbstläufer Als Einzelgänger mit guten Armbrüll wie hunderten Einzelmänner Ich bin kein Rapper Ja, wie kommen wir da jetzt wieder raus? So, es tut uns wahnsinnig leid, wir müssten die Folge leider abbrechen. Das ist noch nie vorgekommen in der Geschichte der 23 Jahre langen Podcast-Erfolggeschichte. Das stimmt nicht ganz. Wir haben schon mal eine Folge abgebrochen, haben sie dann aber nicht veröffentlicht. Das wird die erste Folge Podcast UFO Express, die für zwischendurch sozusagen als Snack, die Snackaufgabe,
falls du mal irgendwie kurz auf dem Weg in die Arbeit oder beim Einkaufen mal kurz so für 30 Minuten was zwischen die Ohren braun.
Das kam jetzt ungefähr so bei mir an.
So, jetzt war die kleine Snackausgabe für zwischendurch.
Naja.
Okay, gut, wir versprechen, dass wir diese Woche noch mal was aufnehmen, was Kleines und noch ein bisschen was hinterherlaufen,
dann vielleicht mit einem musikalischen Gast
und oder einem neuen Hörspiel.
Wir können ja mal eine Bonusfolge machen und die mal
ein bisschen anders aufziehen. Vielleicht mit einem Gast
schickt uns eure... Und ihr könnt uns mal sagen,
wie das gefällt. Vielleicht reicht uns ja eine halbe Stunde,
wir nehmen ja vor zweimal die Woche auf.
Kann man ja auch mal überlegen. In diesem Sinne...
Ja, mehr und dafür kürzer.
In diesem Sinne, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören.
Und wir heben ab.
Like uns auf Facebook, folgt uns auf Twitter und auch ansonsten.
Keine Ahnung, was du und die gerade sagen.
Oder was auch immer.
Macht's gut.
Wir heben ab.
Bis zum nächsten Mal. You're welcome.